les parents de Lola qui viennent tout
juste d'arriver ils sont en train de
saluer le préfet du Pas-de-Calais les
parents de Lola qui n'étaient jamais
encore venu devant les caméras et donc
ils discutent en ce moment avec le
préfet du Pas-de-Calais
[Musique]
voilà la cérémonie hétérotransmise par
des haut-parleurs et ses proches ont
témoigné pendant la cérémonie et rendu
hommage à la petite fille regardez le
témoignage de son frère
ma petite sœur adorée
j'espère que tu m'entends de là-haut
malheureusement tu es parti beaucoup
trop tôt j'ai même pas pu te dire à quel
point je t'aimais
j'espère que j'ai été assez présent pour
toi
dans ta vie même si j'ai l'impression
qu'on a rien pu faire ensemble tellement
que je sais pas si vite
[Musique]
un proche ensuite vous lui prendre la
parole selon BFM il s'agirait de la
maman de Lola d'autres pensent que c'est
la tente de Lola regardez ce témoignage
aussi c'est vrai que quand on voit ça
franchement on est tous à base
bourguignon regardez c'est moi je
regarde je veux entendre mais je regarde
même pas regardez
notre petite Lola aujourd'hui rien
arrête nos larmes
quand il y a encore peu nous te
regardions rire sourire chanter danser
sans te soucier de quoi que ce soit
comme un enfant de ton âge
tu laisseras un grand vide autour de
nous
son départ aujourd'hui nous dévastent et
nous anéantis notre chagrin est immense
sans nul doute mais nous nous attachons
on aurait ta mémoire ma petite princesse
ne pense surtout pas qu'on t'oubliera de
sitôt
on t'aime
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est il y a
de nombreux témoignages voilà qui te
disent
complètement
je vous le dis c'est une horreur
vraiment on va pas
et ce jour on le redoutait tous et
les proches sont bouleversants dignité
quoi c'est ça nous touche au coeur ils
sont ils sont incroyables ils sont d'une
force d'une souffrance de ces bouleverse